[Music]
it was my privilege 26 years ago to
award you your bachelor's degree and 25
years ago your master's degree it was
soon recognised that your first straight
performance as a teacher was matched by
first-rate talent as an administrator
and you were quickly co-opted from one
administrative job after another in fact
you hardly had the opportunity to arm
the chair in one post before you were
drafted for another
it's very nice to have so many people
from so many institutions and so many
old friends who have come back today to
participate in this celebration I got to
know Paul Gray when I was beginning
graduate school but we really became
close when I became his Provost I first
met him through his deep involvement in
undergraduate education at MIT he was a
great friend a great colleague but also
a very great teacher for me
I got involved as an athlete as a
swimmer as a trailer as a sailor and I
would often see him and I would invite
him to our competitions and he would
come and I remember he and Priscilla
coming into swimming me in and just
sitting down and staying for the whole
time he was a quietly very brave
tenacious man loving and kind and gentle
and very focused and always very engaged
he loved being around experts and taking
advice from experts and learning from
experts and sharing with experts he was
the father who took us hiking biking
swimming sailing skating he's the one
who ran behind us when we were learning
to ride our bikes until we could do it
on our own there were no training wheels
you just figured it out
[Music]
Paul began his MIT life as a freshman
Paul came to imagine 1950 so that's
almost 70 years that's just simply
remarkable I can't think of anybody else
who gave so much of his life assured so
much of his life was visited he's a very
down-to-earth individual very
straightforward man but very caring he
did so much for him I teared he did it
oily he did it morning noon at night
he's so devoted to this place and to the
students in such a genuine way he was
never in it for himself he was always in
it for MIT
some years ago in a commencement in the
rain a father was heard to say after the
soaking I've taken for the last four
years who minds a little rain
but I have to say this is something else
in the competitive sport of diving the
various dives are ranked according to
the degree of difficulty when the
performances of different divers are
equal the diver who chooses to dive with
the highest degree of difficulty wins
now by that measure alone you here today
are winners you have chosen and
successfully negotiated a collegiate
education having what may be the
nation's highest degree of difficulty
[Applause]
and we always called it this special
place I think for him it really was a
special place and a kind of home unlike
he'd ever had before because it
satisfied him intellectually and it
satisfied him I think emotionally and
when he was able to connect his own
family to it then I think that that was
sort of a full-circle MIT is best known
for the scientists and engineers who
have studied there he was at MIT at a
time when engineering changed completely
from largely empirical practice of
making things and making them work to a
situation where science and
understanding fundamentals affected the
design and the implementation of so many
systems this very gentle quiet fierce
man I know had to do battle to get
Whitehead Institute established people
were terribly suspicious and you know
frankly he wasn't sure what it would be
nobody was it was an experiment and he
took the risk
MIT and the biomedical Enterprise in
Kendall Square is unrivaled anywhere in
the world and so I do credit Paul with
setting us out in that direction so the
Whitehead we now have the broad and the
Reagan the Koch Institute any number of
expressions of the power of biology to
transform our world when I came to MIT
which was in 1965 I think maybe two or
three percent of the students were women
fewer than that on the faculty it was
very much a male institution he was
tremendously committed to diversity
increasing the representation in the
faculty and in a student body of women
and of minorities the number of entering
african-american students at MIT went
from about three to five per year to 57
to this day I mean we're just very proud
of that momentum upon approach the table
on this issue mit has a responsibility
to itself and to the nation to be open
and indeed to reach out to the most
talented and promising people regardless
of race or sex
none of us created all the bias around
us but we certainly inherit it and what
I love about president Grey is that he
stepped right into that and as soon as
he saw it and understood it he decided
to actually do something about it
during his inauguration what he wanted
as the walking in music was Aaron
Copland's fanfare for the common man and
that was him you know he always was in
touch with his very modest beginnings in
a blue-collar family where you know the
economy was a challenge
one of his fraternity brothers while he
was at MIT as a sophomore was dating a
woman at Wheaton College where my mother
was a freshman they introduced my
parents on what turned out to be a
rather successful blind date
is very cold and they're walking across
the bridge and my mother doesn't have
any gloves and my father said I've got a
pair of gloves why don't we do this I'll
wear the left one you wear the right one
and we'll hold hands to keep the middle
ones warm and they walked across the
bridge and they walked off into the
future that was the first day of their
relationship I thought well that's
that's pretty good for a nerd from New
Jersey
very clever use of a pair of gloves to
win the girl's heart
[Music]
it was the big blizzard of 78 and no
cars were allowed on the road you know
for a week but and whitey was not going
to shut down so we started this bus line
and one of my favorite pictures of Paul
Gray is with his big wolf skin or beaver
skin hat you know we're like a Russian
hat out in the parking lot at MIT where
the buses came in directing traffic I
mean he was very much hands-on he looks
incredibly happy actually in the picture
he was just doing what he could do I
think and having fun doing it I think he
had a lot of joy and what he did
he was a real proponent of the
undergraduate research opportunities
program Europe it was dramatically
successful and found a way for
undergraduates to interact with the
faculty in their research project this
would be a way in which students could
for the first time perhaps in her years
at MIT come to terms with an unsolved
real problem something where they could
make a genuine contribution that became
an integral part of how MIT educate
students so it was a huge thing for us
when he finished up all the
administrative and leadership roles that
he had MIT he went back to the classroom
he loved being in the classroom you
turned the crank on a 3 by 3 matrix and
solve for the node voltages he sub B he
sub C and E sub D he was an absolutely
excellent teacher clarity complete
concern with the students understanding
very much enjoyed being in their company
professor gray was my academic adviser
when I was an undergrad here at MIT and
I remember he was a really warm very
friendly giving advisor at first maybe
you would think it might be a little
intimidating having your advisors would
be the ex-president of MIT but that
turned out not to be the case at all
professor gray was extremely
down-to-earth he really understood
technological education and what of a
technological research university is
really about and how precious it is
[Music]
one of the many involvements that the
greys had with students
what are they senior dinners we invited
the whole class to dinner 60 or 70 at a
time all of us at MIT we just celebrate
the opportunities to be with those
students they are so special every
semester on registration day we would
meet with him and then that evening all
of us all of his advisers would go out
to dinner with him always at the Royal
East if you can imagine there was sort
of a a big table usually in the back of
the restaurant all filled with I'd say
maybe about ten or so advisees yours is
the obligation to help heal with society
where healing is required to help
strengthen the nation's we're
strengthening is required and to help
bring harmony among the nations of this
world wherever discord obtains if you
have ever seen Paul's official
presidential portrait it is a portrait
of Paul in Priscilla he was the first
person to have his spouse in the picture
right and I think that for him that was
a measure of his devotion for her his
appreciation for all the things that my
mother may have sacrificed in order to
help him have the roles and the
opportunities that he had and all the
ways in which she supported him I think
that that was his way of saying you know
I wouldn't have been able to do this
without Priscilla was extraordinary to
watch them together how they work
together how they supported each other
they both had a twinkle in their eye
they were kind of pinging at you
just to know that there was someone sort
of watching over us making sure that
things generally are probably gonna be
okay for us so I really appreciated that
very much he is a man of exceptional
integrity the humanists of the van and
of Priscilla was so essential to the
kind of leadership he provided at MIT he
cared about people
a person with tremendous integrity a
person with tremendous wisdom thoughtful
calm an extraordinarily forceful person
but also with a surprisingly gentle
personality he's good at listening he
was good at negotiating and meeting
people partway and he was good at
imagining what might be possible if this
shifted or that changed or we could move
forward together in this direction as
you undertake this next stage in your
lives I wish for you a life that is rich
in opportunities to stretch your talents
your interests your imagination and your
vision of this small planet as a
beautiful oasis generating peace and as
you depart from this special place I
wish you Godspeed
[Music]
you
[Music]
you